The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So we're here,
but don't forget about this.
And so the quiz
is next Thursday.
I'm going to send an
email out with office
hours for extra time.
But if anyone wants
to meet anytime,
just send me an email, please.
This PSET 2, we decided
is going to be due
the day before on May 9.
And that's when your PSET
3 will be posted as well.
And PSET 3 will have to do with
the things we've been talking
about the last two
lectures and today, which
is what you can do with solids.
Any questions about
the plan, the schedule?
OK.
Right.
Now, there are other
practice problems.
I'll throw one out
from last year's quiz.
So that's a practice
quiz that I gave out
maybe a year ago or two.
And then there's
last year's quiz,
and I'll pull a problem
or two out from that,
and we'll do one today,
and then maybe we'll
look at another one on Tuesday.
What I want to cover in terms
of the lecture material today
is, I want to briefly start
with that band structure
and caspase, and make sure
we're feeling good about it,
and then tell you a few
of the things you can do.
We talked about
the band structure,
we've talked about how it
has so much information.
Well, what other kinds
of information is there?
What can you do with these
sorts of properties of solids?
I love this cartoon.
"At some point, his theory
becomes so abstract,
it can only be conveyed
using interpretive dance."
And mostly it's
because of the visuals
that I get on my colleagues
here at MIT just dancing.
But we're not going to get
this complicated, right?
So the point isn't for me to do
a lecture on transport theory,
and tell you all about phonons
and go into great detail
about these different things.
That is, again, not
been our point here.
The point is to keep relevant
and keep pretty applied
in this class.
So I'm going to give you
just a little hint as to what
you can do with the DOS
and the band structure.
But we're not going to
go into great detail.
But you can find those
details in many places online
and in books.
And if you come to me, I'm happy
to talk about these concepts
that we'll talk about.
So the plan is,
we're going to do
a little bit of review,
caspase, feeling good
about oneness, all that.
And then I want to
show you that problem.
We'll talk about just
one band structure
problem that I happened to
give last year on the exam.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about some properties,
electron transport
a couple of minutes.
And then we'll talk
about magnetization,
and then we'll do some
calculations together again,
because I think that's
been really enjoyable.
Actually, seriously, I always
enjoy calculating together.
But how many of you
feel like that's useful,
to do some simulations
here in class?
One, two, more?
OK.
Because please ask questions.
This is the time.
Because this is where we can, if
you have any questions, please
stop.
And say, I got no idea
what you're talking about.
That's OK.
I love those.
That's what I want to hear.
[LAUGHS] Well, that's actually
not what I want to hear.
But if I hear it, it's fine.
That helps me to
know where we need
to have a little discussion.
Now, this is the
concept that we have
to be really good in
our understanding.
But this is really the
key of this second part
of the second part, if
you want, of the class.
Which is, we did quantum,
we did quantum for atoms,
we did quantum for molecules,
and now it's all about solids.
And the big difference is
that when you have a solid,
you have over and
over and over again,
the same atom, or same couple
of atoms in your basis.
And therefore, the same
potential that the electron
feels.
And over and over
again, how many times?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 2?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: If I
had to give a number.
AUDIENCE: Oh my god,
there's a couple thousand.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well, I'd
say more like a couple of 10
to the 23rd thousands.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
10 to the 23rds.
If I take a piece of material,
this big, this big, even
this big.
Even really tiny.
You got like, 10 23rd
repeats of this potential.
That's a lot.
So it's almost infinite.
And when you have that
periodically repeating
well that the electron
feels, something happens.
And the something
that happens was
this mathematical
thing that, who
can remember what it's called?
It was a theorem, I believe.
AUDIENCE: Bloch's theorem?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Bloch's theorem.
And we don't need to know
much about Bloch's theorem
except the endgame.
The key is what it means.
And it's a mathematical
consequence.
It's a consequence of having
an electron, and therefore
its solution being a
wave function that solves
the Schrodinger equation.
It's a consequence
of having that
in the context of a
periodic potential.
You can't get around it.
It's a theorem.
So because of
Bloch's theorem, you
got to have this
requirement, if you
want to think about
it as a requirement,
that when the wave
function repeats,
the properties just repeat.
The density's the same
here as it is here
as it is here, 10
to the 23rd out.
But when the wave
function repeats,
it picks up this phase.
And that phase is a number
that lives in k-space, that
lives in the inverse space.
And that's why we
spent all that time
talking about what inverse space
is, what reciprocal space is,
what k-space is.
And that phase is, you can think
about it as another quantum
number.
So the result of solving
the Schrodinger equation
and getting psi in
a periodic potential
gives you a new number.
But it's very different
than these numbers.
How is it different?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The vector.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, yeah.
Right.
These are like 1 or 2
or 1, 2, 0, minus 1,
whereas this is
a place in space.
And what else is really
interesting about that vector?
AUDIENCE: It's in
reciprocal space.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's
a reciprocal space.
Absolutely.
Nice job.
You guys did that
together, totally.
Team effort, man.
I love it.
And what else?
It's a vector in
reciprocal space.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Kind of in
the Brillouin zone.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, well,
it doesn't have to be.
But we said it doesn't really
matter if you go outside of it,
because you just loop back.
But what about its variation
in the Brillouin zone?
How can it vary?
AUDIENCE: Anything.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
This is a vector
that can be anything.
This thing can be anything.
These things, can
they be anything?
Can l be pi?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Or
square root of 2, right?
So it's a different
kind of quantum number.
But you see, it has
the same impact.
Because, what do
these things do?
What does this do, anyway?
What's one of the
things that this does?
Or this?
What does l do?
When I change l
from 0 to 1, what's
one of the things that happens?
AUDIENCE: Moving
from, like, s to p?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Yeah, yeah, OK.
So let's write that down.
Well, let's change n up
to here to s, 1s, 2s.
And now you just
said I'm moving to p.
Now, what is this that I'm
always just assuming you know,
is what that vertical axis is?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Fill energy
from lowest to highest.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So this is the energy going
from lowest to highest, exactly.
And so what did changing the
quantum number, l, from 0 to 1
do?
AUDIENCE: It moved from s to p.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
it moves it around.
It moves it around.
OK, so you can
change the energy,
and actually, you can also
not change the energy.
m doesn't change the energy.
It gives degeneracy.
But certainly you
can change the energy
by changing these
quantum numbers.
That's what you can do with k.
That's what k does.
k, which is a result of living
in a periodically repeating
world, k changes the levels.
It's the same idea.
It's very different, but
it has the same impact.
It changes these levels around.
And it's very different because
it can do it continuously,
as opposed to these big leaps
that we have in the atom.
Or in the molecule.
In the molecule, there
are also discrete levels.
And so we got this picture
that we came to last time,
where you see, k
can be a vector.
And it can live anywhere
in this inverse space.
And anytime you change it, you
may change the energy levels.
You may change them.
So it's a really important
thing when you have a solid.
Now, again, if I have a
periodically repeating atom,
but the distance between
them is like, 100 angstroms.
What's the impact
of k going to be?
We did it in class.
AUDIENCE: It's going
to be relatively small.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Relatively small.
Like, almost nothing.
Because the whole effect
comes from the fact
that you have an electron in a
lattice of periodic potentials,
where they're sort
of interacting,
where they're close enough
that there's some interaction.
If there's no interaction,
and your atoms are really,
really far apart,
then it's basically
like you just have
isolated atoms,
sitting in their potentials.
And a whole lot of
empty space in between.
And then the levels
will just look flat
as a function of k-space.
Doesn't mean you can't vary k.
You could still vary k.
But the bands that you get
will be completely flat.
They'll go back to your
molecular level description.
So does everybody see that?
All right.
And we talked about that.
And so then the question was,
well, what playground of k
matters?
And this is something
we talked about,
but it's really important.
So I want to review it here.
So we just said that k
is this new index that
is a continuous variable, that
changes the energy levels.
It moves them around.
OK, so what does that mean
for a calculation, right?
Well, one thing that
it means is that when
I do a calculation, if an
energy level can now do this,
as a function of
k, then that means
I need to actually
do my calculation
with a mesh of k-points.
How fine a mesh do I need?
What's the answer to that?
AUDIENCE: Depends.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Thank you.
On what?
AUDIENCE: How curvy
the bands are.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
How curvy are my bands?
AUDIENCE: Pretty curvy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
This is pretty curvy.
So maybe I need a lot of
k-points to capture this.
You got a grid.
I'm solving for this problem on
a grid of k-points, basically.
And if I only have a
k-point here and here, well,
let's say I have it actually
even worse, I have it here
and here, I'm not
going to really capture
the right physics here.
So the density of
k-points has to be such
that you capture the
features, in terms of how
much these energy levels vary.
So let's go back to these two
atoms that are very far apart.
How many k-points
do I need for those?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What if
they're really far apart?
AUDIENCE: One.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: One.
Whoa.
All the calculations you've been
doing, until we did the solids,
everything before that
was actually 1 k-point.
It was at 000.
We never varied it.
We never worried about it.
It was never an index.
OK, so now, if the
bands are flat,
you could just have
one k-point, and you've
got the variation of the bands
nailed, since they don't vary.
So you just need the one.
But if they vary a lot, like
if I bring atoms together,
and they vary a lot, and
there's a lot of interaction,
then I just need more and more
k-points to represent that
correctly.
OK, so the k-point
is something that's
now an essential part
of your calculation.
Now, that's talking
about what you
need to get the
density right, which
is to get the wave
function right, which is
to get the energy levels right.
That's a new component of a
quantum mechanical simulation.
But then there was
this other thing
that's actually a little
bit separate in a way, which
is to visualize that variation.
Now, visualizing this
variation leads to these plots,
which are called
AUDIENCE: Band structures.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Band structures.
This is the band
structure of the material.
Ooh, it's another
kind of phase map,
for those of you who felt the
excitement of phase diagrams
in 301-2.
This is like a phase
map for that electron.
It's a really
important description
of how electrons
behave in materials.
Everything going OK over there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It
looked like you got hurt.
No, you're good.
OK.
All right, I got a little
concerned, but we're over it.
[LAUGHS] Sorry.
The phase map is a
walkthrough k-space.
Now, I just mentioned that
you have a grid that you just
have to put on here
to do the calculation
to get the wiggles that
may or may not be there.
Well, you should take
a guess it whether you
think they're there,
and then you should see,
and then you should converge it.
But now I'm taking a
walk around in that zone.
And the question is,
where am I going to go?
Well, I'm using 4
by 4 by 4 k-points.
So I'm using a
grid of 64 points.
And I'm plopping it down
into this Brillouin zone.
Should I just look
at the energies
at each of those points?
Well, you could do that, right?
Ideally, you'd like to
be able to visualize
this variation all over
k-space, at every single point.
But why don't we do that?
Tell me why we don't
usually do that.
AUDIENCE: Would we be more
interested in isosurfaces?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, that is true,
but that's more of
a density thing.
So that's where you'd want
to know the isosurfaces
of the charged density.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Once you
know a certain amount,
it's repetitive
throughout this direction.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK,
that's definitely true.
But let's say you
didn't know that.
I'd like to do the most
accurate calculation possible.
Let's say I put a grid over
this k-space of a million
by a million by a million.
Don't do that on the nanoHUB.
We'll get calls.
[LAUGHS] But let's
say I did that.
Now, I've got a
million by a million
by a million points
in here, where
each point has a new set
of energy eigenvalues.
Why can't I just visualize that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would it just
take too long to simulate?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well, it
would take a whole lot of time
to simulate.
What about visualizing
it, though?
How would you visualize that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
3D [INAUDIBLE],, right?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: But see, it's
not even really just 3D, right?
Because at each one
of these points,
I've got a spectrum of energies.
So it would be making
your eigenvalues,
each one into a 3D curve.
And I want to look at them all.
You could do that.
But you got to remember,
if I go down to here,
you can't just do it within
this volume element, right?
My eigenvalues might shift
up, down in different ways,
depending on where I am.
How am I actually
going to see that?
So in a way, what we have is
actually a strong visualization
challenge.
There's sort of a
good story here,
because luckily,
we can just look
at a 2D map of this variation
and get all the information we
need, for almost all materials.
And so, how do you
get it a 2D map?
Well then, instead of
doing the whole of volume,
you just walk through
the volume along lines.
You literally just walk along
this line, and then this line,
and then down, and
then back, and then up.
And as you're doing this
walk through k-space,
you plot the energy bands,
and you connect them together.
And you draw lines
between those connections.
This is the same
energy level just
moving around, along that walk.
So that seems like an
oversimplification,
because I'm not going through
the whole Brillouin zone
by any means.
I'm just going through very
particular lines in there.
And yet it's all we need.
And the reason is that
most of the things
I want to know about a
material, most of the things
I want to know,
are going to come
from the variation in these
bands between high symmetry
points in k-space.
So I can go to other points
in the Brillouin zone,
and I'll get other levels.
I'll get a different
set of levels.
But it's probably
not going to add
to my knowledge of the
material and the properties
that I can get.
So for example, I'm
very interested in this
where this has a maximum,
the valence band, and where
the conduction band
has a minimum, right?
And you'll notice, the
minimum for silicon
is actually not at this
high symmetry point x.
But it does come along the path
to x from another high symmetry
point, gamma.
It came along that path.
And there's no place in k-space
that gives me a lower point,
you see.
So I nailed the thing
I needed I nailed it
by going from one high
symmetry point to another.
And that's what a
band diagram is.
It's a walk through
k-space along lines
between high symmetry points.
And that gives you
the map that you need.
And these sometimes look really
complicated, but just think,
it's saving you a
whole lot of trouble
compared to all the data
you actually could have.
But it's giving
you what you need.
Are there any
questions about that?
That's sort of the key point
here from this band structure.
And we've talked about this,
how you get your bands,
just like in an
atom or a molecule.
You get your energy levels
from solving the Schrodinger
equation.
And then you fill them up,
using the Pauli exclusion rule,
right?
Add a little bit of
Hund's rule to it,
although that can be violated.
Don't tell anyone.
And you fill them up
and then you're done.
And when you're done, you've
got your Fermi energy.
Now, it's the same exact thing
here in the band structure.
You fill your bands up,
until you've filled them
up with the number
of electrons that you
had in your simulation.
And then you've got
your Fermi energy,
and then if there's a small gap
there, and no bands cross it,
it cannot be a what?
It cannot be a--
AUDIENCE: Conductor.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: A metal.
It can be a conductor.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It can be
a conductor, a semiconductor,
or a really bad insulating
conductor, also known
as an insulator.
But it can't be a metal.
Because if no bands cross,
if there's a gap here
between where you filled
to and the next place,
then it's not a metal.
So we talked about that.
And that's,
certainly if you have
an odd number of electrons,
it has to be a metal.
And there's a calculation,
I showed this last time
of an insulator.
And we also talked about
how this density of states
is another really
important thing here.
And since this is in
your homework as well,
in your current PSET, I'll
get to transport in a sec.
I want to make sure we know
what density of states is.
Somebody tell me what the
density of states of the carbon
atom would look like.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
OK, so let's draw.
So we had the carbon atom
would have 1s and 2s and 2p.
And how many would I put here?
AUDIENCE: 2.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, and
what about the next one?
AUDIENCE: 2.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
OK, I'm liking it.
And here?
AUDIENCE: 2.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: 2?
OK, like that.
AUDIENCE: Aw.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Oh, wait, hold on.
OK, thank you, like this.
Oh, sorry.
All right.
That would be an
open shell singlet.
Thank you very much.
OK, now.
OK, so what's my density
of states over this?
How do I do it?
OK, yeah.
So I'm seeing
people go like this.
So this was energy here.
And now this is going
to be energy here.
OK, what's my next step?
AUDIENCE: Drawing a curve.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Drawing a curve.
OK, I'm going to draw a curve.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: 1s.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's 1s.
Why not?
I've just broadened it.
We'll make that 1s.
And what's my next
curve I want to draw?
OK, sure.
And it should be
spaced such that it
should be the right
energy spacing
that I get from my quantum
mechanical simulations.
OK.
And what's next?
2p.
Let's make this go out further.
OK, now 2p.
Now, how should I do this?
Should I make it the same?
AUDIENCE: Or shift it
down [INAUDIBLE] energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Shift it down.
AUDIENCE: Same.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Same.
Is it different than 2s?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, let's see.
I had two electrons
in each of these.
How many electrons
could go into 2p?
AUDIENCE: 6.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: 6.
So I actually have
more states there.
I have 3 times as many as here.
So in a way, if you're
thinking about these
as sort of a vertical
line, that is spread out
by some smoothing
function, just to make it
into a nice, pretty curve, if
it's an atom, if it's really
an atom, then it's
really just a line.
It's a delta function.
But then this should have three
lines all on top of each other,
right?
And so if I look
at that, it's going
to lead to a bigger peak,
that has more area under it.
Three times as much, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK.
So you can fit 6
electrons into this peak.
This is what the density
of states is, right?
It is the density of states.
[LAUGHS] It is these levels.
It's these levels.
OK.
Does everybody see that?
Now, where's my Fermi
energy for the carbon atom?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Is it over here?
AUDIENCE: No.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Here?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It feels
like it should be here, right?
We like Fermi energies
between peaks,
but that's just because
we like semiconductors.
No, we like metals
too, and insulators.
They're all good.
So where should it be?
Does this sound good?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Over here?
Hmm?
Somebody tell me when to stop.
Somebody say stop.
AUDIENCE: Stop.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
OK, now why am I stopping here?
So that's my Fermi energy
for the carbon atom.
Why is it there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, it's an atom.
So let's not think about it
necessarily as conducting.
AUDIENCE: It's where
you stop filling.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: That's
the definition, right?
Here I filled and I stopped.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So here I filled and I
stopped, and here I filled
and I stopped.
And what the gentleman
over there said is,
it's where you stop
filling, right?
And so here is where
I stop filling,
because I had this
peak of states, right?
It's a peak of states, the
density of states, that is only
filled by 2 electrons, right?
Does everybody see that?
So if I had something
else, like say, neon,
would my Fermi energy
be inside the peak?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: No.
AUDIENCE: It would be just out.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Just
outside of it, because I
would have filled it, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Besides the change
in the location of the Fermi
energy, would the density states
look the same for nitrogen?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Very good question.
It would, actually.
In the sense that if
you're looking at atoms,
a density of states
is a little bit
of an odd thing for an atom.
But I'm trying to explain
it in the context of atoms,
because I really want you
guys to see the connection,
and really what it is.
But if you look
at atoms, they're
nothing more than levels.
And those discrete levels
become little shapes
that you broaden a little.
So it would look the
same as nitrogen,
because in nitrogen,
you would have that.
Now, what does that do?
Well, it'll change these
energy level positions.
It'll shift them around.
This may even change.
The 1s may go down or up,
this may change a little.
And then here, you're going
to change not the peak,
because you still got
6 states, and you still
got 6 electrons you
can put in there.
But you will change the
Fermi energy within the peak,
because you can
fill it by one more.
And just like going all
the way back to our first
or second lecture, where we had
the orbitals of the hydrogen
atom.
So we had the nucleus
and we had this electron
that does not orbit.
But there it is orbiting.
And then we had the 1s,
and then we had the 2s.
And remember how
we talked about,
it can actually make
transitions between the two
without actually
existing between the two.
There are some times
it has to cross paths,
which are totally forbidden.
It's sort of exciting,
it's like some sort
of interesting fiction.
That this electron is
going on an adventure.
And well, that's
what this is, right?
There is no state in
here, in this energy.
So the DOS tells you that too.
That is what's in the DOS.
That information is
contained in the DOS.
There cannot be an electron with
an energy where there's no DOS,
there's no states
to support it there.
So for an atom, like the
hydrogen atom or the carbon
atom as well, that's
fairly obvious,
because you had your
levels and you knew it.
Couldn't be in
between those levels.
That's the quantization
stuff we talked about.
But now when you get to solids,
and it's a more messy picture.
But it's the same understanding
that you get out of it.
It's the same exact
understanding.
So what you do for
atom, molecule, or solid
is you take your levels
and you turn them over,
and you count up the
number of states,
and that has to be the same.
And you get shapes to the DOS.
If it was an atom, I just
had these little lines
here from the levels,
and I broaden them.
Now, the levels
are no longer flat.
If it's a solid, they can vary.
And when you turn
that on its side,
it can be really
different, right?
But it's telling
you the same thing.
It's telling you
exactly the same thing.
You're filling your
electrons up through here.
And you're stopping,
well, I don't know,
is that the Fermi energy?
I didn't tell you.
But if it is, then
you're stopping there.
And those are your unoccupied
bands, and so forth.
Does everybody see that?
It's the same idea.
But it's more complicated when
you have these curvinesses.
Yeah.
Right?
We good?
Sort of?
Any questions?
Thoughts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
looking at allotropic systems--
so in this case, you have done--
I'm assuming that
the graphite, this
would be completely different.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Completely different.
AUDIENCE: And so
how does that tie
to solving the
density of states?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: You
can write the density
of states for any material.
And the same concept
always holds, right?
That you have these
accessible places where
the electron can be,
with some probability
of them being there, right?
In other words, it's
all about how many
possible energy levels you
have as a function of energy.
That's really what it is.
And so, whatever material you
have, the density of states
simply has the same meaning,
but it will look very different.
And in diamond, you're
going to get a big bandgap,
and in graphite,
well, it's a metal.
In graphene, you have
a crossing at one
part in the band structure,
goes right through what
would have been the gap.
OK?
And that's why when you do your
homework, when you do PSET 5,
there are two ways I want
you to think about how
these molecules absorb light.
One way is that they
just have some cutoff,
below which in energy or
above which in wavelength,
they cannot absorb light.
So that's just a single cutoff.
But the other way
is to actually use
the features in
this plot of levels,
of accessible states
for the electrons,
to use this information
and weight the absorption
of the sun by this.
Because that's actually what's
really going on, is that
the molecule cannot absorb the
same at all the wavelengths
of light.
Because in some places it
can't absorb any light.
In some parts of the DOS,
there's no probability.
So that turns out to
have a really big impact.
OK.
Questions, thoughts?
Now, let me, before
I go on, it's OK.
I thought maybe we'd have time
to look at Intro to Solar,
but that would have
been ahead anyway.
Oh wait, no.
Where is the view?
Huh.
That's not looking very good.
I had what I thought was a
nice example of a problem.
No.
Hang on one second.
Oh boy.
Never show anyone your
desktop in a presentation.
That's a bad idea.
But anyway, oh, final quiz.
AUDIENCE: That's last year.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
that's from last year.
Yeah, don't worry.
It's in a very safe
location for this year.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Actually,
it's very unsafe, it's up here.
Anyway, wait.
Where did it go?
Ah.
Why can't I see it?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Here we go.
OK, that's the problem
I wanted to talk about.
OK, so this was a problem
from last year's quiz.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, so your
advisor has just spilled coffee
on the culmination of your
entire summer UROP work.
This is not a true story.
The prediction of
the band structure
and of an amazing new
material for solar cells.
Unfortunately, in your
excitement to show your work,
you forgot to back up your data.
You dropped your
computer in a hot tub
and you forgot
everything you did.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So you
only have that one printout
now stained with coffee.
Can you believe it?
This is what you got.
Nothing else.
OK?
Was this material-- you want
to put it back together,
because you know-- it
was 4:00 in the morning,
you had had a lot of NoDoz.
But still, you're
pretty sure you
remember it was going to change
the whole field of solar, OK?
Now, from this, was
this material metal,
a semiconductor,
or an insulator?
AUDIENCE: Semiconductor.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Tell me why.
Really?
Seriously?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't look like
The bands are crossing.
Looks like the tallest
bandgap is just under the 0.
I can't really tell.
And then it doesn't
seem like the bandgap
for the bands is
crossing, either.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It
doesn't look like it?
Can you be certain?
AUDIENCE: No.
It's also a fuller cell.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well,
you do need metal,
and maybe it was a revolution
in the metal contact.
That wouldn't revolutionize
solar PV, but still.
Again, see, we're
inclined to want
to connect these things up.
We're sort of used to
staring at silicon,
and we think that's
going to do that.
But I don't know that you
have enough information here.
I'm not sure you know
enough about this
to know that this band didn't
actually split, and one of them
crossed up and went this way.
How do you know?
There is one thing
you know it's not.
There's one of those
three you know it's not.
AUDIENCE: It's not an insulator.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Not an insulator.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Because you can make out
at least that much,
that these bands,
they're about an
EV or two apart.
They may be closer,
they may overlap.
But it is not going to
be an insulator, right?
But you can't tell.
So this a little bit
of a tricky question.
You seem to remember that the
material would absorb light
very efficiently.
Reconstruct the
band structure plot
that would correspond
to such a material.
What are you
supposed to do here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
associated with some wavelength
or a region of
wavelengths alike.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, you
could certainly do that.
And in a way, any band
structure above the bandgap
is associated with
the region of light.
Because except for the bandgap,
below which you cannot absorb
light, as soon as you
start having states,
you can absorb light.
But the key is here.
It absorbs light
very efficiently.
So what do I need to do in here?
AUDIENCE: Put a direct bandgap.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
You got to put a direct
bandgap in there somehow.
That's the key.
So you got to reconstruct this.
And it didn't
matter to me where.
And there were all kinds
of really creative curves
people drew.
But somewhere in
here, maybe this
is going to come down a
little and then go down here.
And then maybe come in like
here, where you can't see.
But somehow, you got to try
to make this a direct bandgap
material.
It's actually pretty
hard, because the stain
doesn't give you a lot of room.
But it's actually, that
mirrors how hard it
is to do that for
silicon in real life.
The stain and silicon
are deeply connected.
One minute later, you
realize that actually, it
didn't absorb light
efficiently at all,
but instead it was a
revolutionary metal electrode.
Now what would you draw?
AUDIENCE: Overlapping.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Right.
You'd cross it up.
Maybe you'd try to get
a lot of wiggles in here
if you could, or just
certainly several crossings,
so that the electrons
don't really see any gap.
You can't see a gap.
So that's kind of
a nice problem.
And you can see, there's
not a very long problem.
But you've got to know a few
things to answer the question
about these sorts of topics.
OK, so we'll do another one
of those next Tuesday, or two.
Wait, where am I here?
Let's talk about a
few other properties
that you can calculate.
Again, I'm not going to go
into the details of transport.
But this is sort of basic
double E or basic physics stuff.
If you put an
electron in a field,
it's going to push
it with a force.
And so the F equals ma of that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] absorb
things that are greater here.
It absorbs light that has
energy greater than the gap.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Greater than the gap.
AUDIENCE: But don't you
want a very small gap
for a semiconductor?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
For what application?
For solar cells?
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah, sure.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So
that's a very good point.
And who can tell me why you
can't have too low of a gap?
And I'll talk about this
as we move into solar PV.
AUDIENCE: Because I think the
barrier's not high enough,
and they keep hopping over.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: That wouldn't
necessarily be a problem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It would probably get
saturated with lower energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: And what's
wrong with that, though?
AUDIENCE: You're not
going to be able to use
the full potential of the cell.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well,
that's what it is, is it
actually is what sets the
potential of the cell.
So this goes back to, and it's
a very good question, right?
Why not just use the
lowest gap possible?
And then you'll absorb all the
light, or most of the light.
Well, the reason is that it
goes back to this picture
that when you're taking photons
and making them into electrons,
what you're really
doing is it's again,
it's that pumping water analogy.
You're giving the
electrons energy
and pushing them up a hill.
Now, in the solar
fuel's case, we're
using that push to change
the molecule's configuration
to store energy.
In the solar cell case,
we're using that push
to get just energy,
voltage out, right?
So I'd like to not get just a
teeny, teeny bit of voltage.
I'd like to get it up a hill.
Now, if I make my band gap such
that I can only push it really,
really high, you might
think you want that.
But then what happens?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
absorb any light.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Doesn't absorb any light.
So now you have these
two competing effects.
AUDIENCE: Small bandgap.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
To absorb the light.
Larger bandgap to give you
more potential for yourself.
AUDIENCE: And large bandgap,
more potential, small bandgap,
small potential.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
But more light.
And there's a sweet spot.
And I'll talk about that.
I'll talk about that a
little bit on Tuesday.
That that is two competing
attributes of solar PV
that limit how much energy
you can get from the sun.
So if you put an
electron in a field,
it's going to move until you
hit this equilibrium point where
the acceleration is 0,
because the force it feels
is balanced by the scattering.
That's sort of basic transport,
electron transport equations.
And so you can get an equation
for the drift velocity
of the electron.
Or the thing that
we care about a lot
is this electrical conductivity,
something that you can measure,
which is nothing more than the
drift velocity times the number
density.
That's actually a hard
thing to separate out,
but it can be done
in experiment.
And so the current
is that, and it's
equal to the electrical
connectivity times the field.
Now, here's the thing.
That equation, then, if you
just look at these very simple F
equals ma for an
electron in a field,
that very simply comes
down to this equation.
And here's the thing.
That mass, what we
want now is, well,
what's the electron
conductivity in the solid?
What's the electron
And it turns out
that that mass that's
on the previous page,
that m, it becomes
a kind of effective mass
of the electron that
can be different
than just the mass
of the electron, the standard
mass of the electron.
The reason is that it's
in this periodic crystal.
Remember, the electron
is going to feel
this very strange
environment when
it's in a periodic crystal.
And it's going to feel
differences in its energy band.
And what that does
is it changes,
actually the effective
mass of the electron,
as it's in different
parts of k-space.
Well, it turns out that that
effective mass is directly
related to this curvature.
I'm just rewriting
the previous equation,
but now I'm putting in
the band structure here.
These little v's are nothing
more than the slope of E
in the band structure,
the slope of the energy
in the band structure versus k.
So this is called effective
mass approximation.
It's an approximation, but
it's a pretty good one.
The electron feels a
different weight to it.
It's heavy or light.
Think about it that way.
Depending on whether it's in
a flat part of the band, where
it's really heavy,
or whether it's
in a curvy part of
the band, where it's
feeling more light and bouncy.
And that changes
the connectivity
that can be measured.
So just from the
curvature of these bands,
it's a really nice
way of getting
a sense of how mobile
an electron or hole is
in a material.
All you have to do
is you just take
an integral over the
derivative of the slope,
basically, as you go
along k-space there.
So does anybody know
what a Fermi function is?
It's just a wait.
But-- yeah?
How many of you don't know
what a Fermi function is?
OK.
So this comes from
Fermi-Dirac statistics.
It's not in any
way critical here.
But it's an occupation function.
It's saying that at
a given temperature,
you're likely to have electrons
or not at a certain energy.
And so the Fermi function
at 0 temperature,
F is going to look like this.
Where this would be 1,
and this would be 0.
And the Fermi
function is 1 over e
to the E minus EF
divided by KT, plus 1.
Where e is where
you are in the band
structure. e is where you
are in the band structure,
and you're looking at this as
you go above the Fermi energy.
Can electrons be there?
Well, at 0 temperature, no.
But actually, when you go
to some finite temperature,
just temperature alone
can kick electrons up.
OK, that's what the Fermi
function is in that equation
for.
Because at some temperature,
you can actually
have a distribution that
looks more like this.
T equals 0, T equals something.
Now, what's important here?
Well, what's
important is that when
you think about conductivity,
you want to know, you see.
The difference here between
drift velocity and current
or connectivity is that you
got to know something about how
many carriers you have.
And that's going to be
temperature-dependent.
Does everybody see that?
That's why this is important.
Now, but what if my Fermi
function is like this?
And OK, let's say
I have silicon,
and I'm going to now
plot on top of this,
I'm going to use a different
color, and plot on top of this
the density of states.
And let's say my density
of states was like this.
OK, I don't know
if it is or not.
And then here's the bandgap.
This is my DOS.
That doesn't look like a
different color at all.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's not even close.
It's like they painted
it yellow on the outside.
And seriously,
it's totally white.
All right, anyway.
So here's my Fermi function.
I'm at room
temperature, and this is
my distribution of electrons.
This is the gap.
Tell me what's going on here.
Somebody explain this to me.
Yeah, Sam?
AUDIENCE: Even though
there's probability
that you can have electrons
in that space, because there's
no space for them to go,
you still [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I love it.
That's absolutely right.
You cannot have electrons there.
The Fermi function says I can.
In your face, Fermi
function, says the DOS.
I didn't say that.
I would never say that
to a Fermi function.
But the DOS said it.
The DOS said, uh-uh!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: We got
zero probability here, man!
You can't be here.
So the DOS said,
no states, no deal.
Go away.
So the Fermi function tried.
It said, hey, I got enough
energy from temperature
to give you a few electrons.
And the DOS says,
I don't want them.
Because they're not at
the energy where I've got
any states.
Now, what can I do,
then, to populate
the conduction band of silicon?
What can I do?
AUDIENCE: More thermal energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
More thermal energy.
I'm going to run my solar
cell at 10,000 degrees.
Well, you'll get more and more.
And you will start to
get electrons in there.
But actually, that's
not always practical.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So how do
we get electrons into there?
Then there are other
reasons electrons
come into those states,
not just from thermal.
But what's one way that we
can get electrons in there?
AUDIENCE: Doping.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
What does doping do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
changes it from energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well, it
can change it from the energy.
But what might I
dope silicon with?
AUDIENCE: Phosphorus.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Phosphorus.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Excess electron.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Excess electron,
but compared to silicon.
Now, if I have an excess
electron sitting in my crystal,
but really the crystal is
still kind of silicony,
because I don't have many
of these excess electrons.
I just have one phosphorus
atom every 1000.
So it's really still silicon.
But I filled all my
electrons up to here.
And now I've got one extra.
Where does it go?
AUDIENCE: It goes in there.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Goes in there.
And now I'm populating it
without thermal energy, right?
I don't need to work
with my Fermi function,
I did it chemically.
I put an atom in there that
had a spare electron, right?
And that is actually,
in fact, exactly what
happens in real materials.
Who knows what it's called when
you have an extra electron,
or an excess of electrons?
AUDIENCE: N-type?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: N-type.
Now, what if I wanted holes?
What if I wanted extra holes?
AUDIENCE: B-type.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: B-type.
And what would I put in there?
AUDIENCE: Boron.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Boron.
Because?
AUDIENCE: It's an electron.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's an electron.
Now, you could dope it
with many other things.
You don't have to dope silicon
with just phosphorus or boron.
It turns out that those
are easy and there
are some advantages in
terms of their processing,
and chemically,
they can be happy.
But there are many ways
of doping materials.
Many, many ways of
doping materials.
And one of the things
you do with doping,
there are many things
you do with doping.
But one of the things you do
is you get electrons or holes
into these bands.
You populate them, right?
But this expression
is ignoring that.
This is just saying,
well, we're going
to see if there's some
thermal energy there,
and we'll use that.
OK?
Yeah.
Any questions about that?
Now, we talked about this a lot.
So I'm not going to
go over this again,
that the direct transitions
are easy for photons.
The indirect ones where you
shift where you are in k-space
are hard, OK?
And that is why silicon is
an expensive solar cell.
So we talked about
this, and I don't
want to belabor the
point, because I
want to try to get to some
simulations, if possible.
Any questions about that
point, though, the optical
transitions?
All right.
So the kinds of
things you can get.
Well, you can get optical
properties, right?
And you can also get
magnetic properties
from these densities of states.
So we talked about the
optical properties.
And the optical properties is
really the context of your PSET
5, but it's for a molecule.
We haven't talked
about megnetism,
and I want to come back to
it, because I did mention
that electrons have spin.
And therefore, they also
have a magnetic moment.
And we call this, just
think of it as some constant
that we call the Bohr magneton.
It has a value.
Well, and if you think
about an atom or a molecule,
you could just get that by
knowing how many electrons
are spinning in one direction
more than the other, right?
So you can just count
how many spin up
electrons minus how many
spin down electrons you have,
and multiply that by
the Bohr magneton.
And that will give you
the magnetic moment
of the atom or molecule.
But what would I do for a solid?
Do I still have it?
Yeah.
See, there's the atomic picture
where I could just count.
And in this case,
the difference is 3.
Right?
But now, I've got a solid.
So what do I want to do?
What do I want to
look at for a solid?
AUDIENCE: Density of states.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Density of states.
And it turns out
that you can plot
the density of states for spin
up and spin down electrons
separately.
And they can be different.
They can occupy the
two spins differently
in a more complicated
way, but very much same
idea as what can happen
in and out of them.
But it's more
complicated as you get
these curvy bands and
all kinds of other things
that can happen in a solid.
So now, you look at the separate
density of states for electrons
with spin up versus spin down.
And that is something that
I didn't talk about yet.
It's an input
parameter in SIESTA
that is checked yes
by default. And it's
called spin polarized,
question mark,
I think is what it's called.
Spin polarized?
I should give the
right intonation.
And you say yes or no.
And you say yes, because
that's the default.
But what are you doing
when you say yes?
Well, what you're
doing is you're
telling the calculation to
allow the up and down electrons
to have freedom
from one another.
That's actually critical.
So if you didn't
do that, you would
be simulating the material
with the constraint
that the up and down
electrons are exactly
at the same energies.
So spin polarized,
the reason you
do calculations that
are not spin polarized
is because many
systems don't have
a difference between up
and down electrons, right?
And they are actually
all the same, right?
What do I have if
I fill this up?
What atom is that?
AUDIENCE: Neon.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's neon.
And here, every up electron is
the same as every down electron
for a given state.
Everything is the same here.
So it's not like this up
electron of this p orbital
wanted to be there, and the
down one wanted to be there.
That doesn't happen for neon.
And it doesn't happen for many
systems and many materials.
But certainly in some
cases, and certainly
for magnetic materials,
that's what causes magnetism.
It's that you have a difference
between spin up and spin down.
And that as you occupy
the density of states,
literally you get a difference
in the number, right?
So that's what
causes the magnetism.
So for many materials, there
is no spin polarization.
Or in other words,
there is no difference.
Spin up and spin down
is the same here,
same here, same here.
But if it's a magnetic
material, what you'll find
is that if you plot
the density of states
separately for spin
up and spin down
electrons, like in this case
for iron, there's a difference.
And in fact, the magnetic
moment of that material
is nothing more than the
integral of that difference.
Again, you're
integrating the DOS.
And you're finding something
really cool about the material.
So that's the same
thing as just counting
number of up a number
of down, but now you're
counting it in this very
complex filling of states
that happens in a material.
Any questions?
So if I did a calculation
of iron with spin polarized
checked no, then you see,
these would be identical.
And I'd get no magnetism.
And you can do that.
You can actually do
the calculation of iron
with spin polarized checked
no, and it's completely wrong.
It's not the ground
state of iron.
And if you do it with
spin polarized on,
then it allows those
up and down electrons
to move relative to each other.
And the outputs, you'll
see that in the plots,
there's something called the
projected density of states.
And it's projected for
one spin and another spin.
And that would allow
you to calculate
the magnetic
properties of materials
using the nanoHUB tool.
And I think last year we might
have done a homework on that.
But this year, we won't.
But I want you to know about
it, because it's kind of cool.
OK?
Any questions?
Mm-hm.
A couple other
things you can do,
and first principles,
quantum molecular dynamics,
you can do it.
You can do MD, Just like you
did MD in the first part.
You're just getting f from the
Hellmann-Feynman theorem, which
I referred to a
couple lectures ago.
But it's basically just a
way of getting the forces
using quantum mechanics.
And I don't really want
to go into it in detail,
but I just want to
tell you, you can
get the force on these atoms
from these quantum mechanical
simulations.
And you can do dynamics.
Here's one I did
a long time ago.
And here the problem was
that, how do nanotubes grow,
which was a big question, OK?
And so what you have is, you
have a piece of iron here.
And this is what
happens when you
grow nanotubes, is you
have these seed particles,
like iron.
It can be other things,
nickel, other things will work.
Not gold.
And then you flow some
kind of gas over it
that dumps carbon
onto the catalyst.
Now, the problem is that
understanding how that then
leads to the growth of a tube
is still an open question,
by the way.
Still an open question.
Nobody actually really knows
the full answer to that.
But certainly, people
were just debating,
does the carbon go inside
the catalyst or not?
Does it stay on the surface,
does it saturate the catalyst
first, and then come out from
the bulk, from the particle?
And that's a perfect
problem for quantum,
because there's so many
different bonding environments,
and so many possibilities here,
that classical potentials will
fail.
They're not going to capture all
of the different complexities
in how carbon needs to bond
to iron, inside and out.
And so it's a great problem
for quantum mechanics.
And we studied this, and we
fed the simulation carbon,
and we just watched how the
tube winds up making its way out
of the system.
And we showed that it
doesn't saturate, actually,
inside the iron, but rather
stays on the surface.
And it makes for cool movies.
Somebody tell me something
you notice about this.
Besides just, it's
kind of a fun movie.
But do you notice anything?
There's the initial
nanotube growth.
And that's where it ended.
So I notice two things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Some rings
are more than 6 carbons.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Oh yeah.
Actually, that's a
really good point.
So that was a very interesting
part of the analysis is,
what kind of carbon you get.
When you catalyze carbon on
a surface, what does it do?
Does it form nice graphene
and then curve it?
Or does it form the defects
so that you can curve it?
Where are the penalties
in energy coming from?
But actually, I was going to
say some negative things, two
negative things.
They're not negatives,
but they're limitations.
Tell me something
obvious about this
compared to, say, the
protein simulations
we did in the first part.
AUDIENCE: Very small.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
This is really tiny.
And how long do you
think this went?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What is that?
AUDIENCE: When was it found?
What year?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I'm not
going to tell you, because that
would make me feel old.
A while ago.
[LAUGHS] But anyway,
how long can you
run a molecular dynamics
simulation having to do
quantum mechanics at each step?
AUDIENCE: Very short period.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well,
how long could you
do proteins with classical MD?
Huge systems.
Could you do them for seconds?
No.
But how long?
AUDIENCE: Milliseconds?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
actually even longer.
With classical MD, you can
get up to microseconds now.
Certainly nanoseconds, just 10,
100 nanoseconds, no problem.
Here, we're at 10
picoseconds, right?
Even 2 picoseconds.
Nowadays, you can push
50, 100 picoseconds,
but you wouldn't go
further than that.
It's really hard.
So the time and size
are really limited.
And that's why with
quantum MD, you
study small systems
for short timescales.
This was now cluster growth.
I think quantum, these are
just other things you can do.
This is supposed
to be just making
sure you see that it's not
just the band structure in DOS.
There are other things.
You can do a lot of things
with quantum simulations.
Water is a really cool problem.
And I love Cavendish.
I love reading about Cavendish.
Has anybody read
about Cavendish?
He's such a fascinating guy.
He's a university dropout.
He compared the
connectivities of electrolytes
and expressed a version of
Ohm's law way ahead of time.
And he measured the
gravitational constant.
And he came up with really
water, which at that point
was phlogiston and
dephlogisticated air, which
I love those names.
Which is hydrogen and oxygen.
But anyway, water has these
really interesting properties.
This is a wonderful website
to read about water.
I'll give you the answer.
It actually looks like this.
Water sees water like
this, not like this.
So it really sees it
much more spherical
than we usually draw it.
And yet, it does have these
very definite bondings
that it likes to do.
And the point I want to make
is, when you go into an MD code,
and you put water in
there, did you use water
in your protein simulations?
Yeah.
Which water did you pick?
You must have
picked a potential,
or the code picked a potential.
Right?
Tip 3P to 4P.
Well, there's hundreds of them.
These are just a few
water potentials.
Why are there so many?
Well, because some of them
reproduce some things better
than others, right?
And that gets to be a
really serious problem
if you want to study some of the
fundamental problems of water.
And there's so many mysteries
that we still don't know,
in terms of what happens when
water evaporates, freezes.
And so, which one is best?
Well, this is a perfect
problem for quantum mechanics.
And I won't go
through the details.
But you can do
water with quantum.
And this is a good
way to validate
which potential you use in
your classical simulations.
You can also calculate phonons.
You can just displace atoms and
calculate energy differences,
and get frequencies.
So you can calculate phonons.
And when you calculate
photons in a crystal,
that's different
than in a molecule.
When you calculate
phonons in a crystal,
you're getting the,
waves the sound waves.
You're going to get the acoustic
waves in the material, right?
You're just using water.
In a water molecule, how
many phonon modes do I have?
In a water molecule?
Who can tell me?
Take a guess.
AUDIENCE: 6.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's a good guess.
Let's get rid of
translational and rotational.
How many waves can the
water molecules stretch?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
there's actually three, right?
Because the OHs can stretch,
and the bond can stretch.
But then there's two different
ways that it can go, right?
And so those are your phonon
modes for the molecule.
It's just stretch
frequencies, right?
And they can be measured.
In a solid, you calculate
your phonon modes
by moving atoms
around in the lattice.
And that actually
gives you the behavior
of the sound waves in the
material, which tells you
something about how sound
travels in the solid,
and you can calculate
the sound velocity,
you can calculate
thermal transport.
You can calculate the heat
capacity of the material.
All of this are things that
we do with quantum mechanics
that we're not going to
do in any of our problems,
or anymore.
But I just wanted you to be
aware of some of the things
that people do in
research, and that
are really a big part of
quantum mechanical simulations.
So those are some
of the properties.
So that was sort
of the point here.
You can do a wide calculator,
a wide range of properties.
This has been our
focus, these two.
And we're going to
stay with that focus.
But there's a very large
range of things you can do.
Now, I want to just end.
I got 5 minutes, OK?
And we'll start solar
with this on Tuesday.
But for five minutes, I
want to do a simulation.
So we'll start solar on Tuesday.
But here we are.
You know which tool it is.
It's our favorite.
AUDIENCE: Are we
[INAUDIBLE] Tuesday, or no?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: And we'll
do another problem or two
in class.
And I can do a little review.
I sort of did that on
Tuesday of this week.
Does anybody want to do
more review next week?
What do you guys think?
A little bit?
Yeah?
OK.
What I'll do next
Tuesday is we'll
do another quiz problem from
last year like we did today.
I'll ask if you have any
questions about this practice
quiz but, I'll also
post the solutions.
And I'll go over some key things
to keep in mind for the quiz.
So we'll spend the first
half of class on that, then.
But let me just spend the
last few minutes here.
Let's do a simulation.
AUDIENCE: It's
open notes, right?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's open notes.
Open notes, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does that
mean computer is open?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I think no.
Because that's like,
everything, right?
What did you guys do
in the first part?
AUDIENCE: We had the computers.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: You
had the computers?
AUDIENCE: We had the
computers, but we weren't
allowed to use the internet.
So I don't know how
they were checking that.
But I [INAUDIBLE] my
computer, so I don't know.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK,
let's put it this way.
If we do open computers, then
I'll make the problems harder.
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK.
[LAUGHS] All right.
Because Wikipedia's
pretty powerful, right?
And Google.
And so if you have that, you
can find a lot of close answers
with a quick search.
So I'd have to be a
little more creative.
But you won't need
your computers.
And it's full open notes, right?
OK.
Now here's what I wanted to do.
Let's go to our favorite
thing here, SIESTA.
There it is.
So I wanted to show you first
of all, this feature here,
which is that spin polarized.
Do you see?
Yes?
No.
OK?
Now, when it's yes, and
I calculate silicon,
here's the calculation of the
density of states of silicon,
is what I want to show you.
What you are going to find.
Oh, I didn't fill
out the structure.
Is that, OK, so this
is just rounding out
our SIESTA understanding
of what the tool does.
Because there were just
these few things that
we hadn't talked about.
This is the density of states.
And you now really feel
your oneness with this.
You know what these are.
You look at this, and you
get emotional, which is OK.
But look at this.
I also have here,
because I did, let's see
if it does this right.
Total, and there.
Look at that, OK.
You see, it's
automatically doing
what's called the projected
density of states.
And what a projected density
of states is, is it's
the density of states, but
only for a certain part
of the system.
Which turns out to be
really interesting.
Like sometimes you just
want to know the density
of states for one type of atom.
Where is that atom
contributing to the states?
Or in this case, because
it has been polarized,
it's giving me the density of
states for spin down and spin
up separately.
And look at this.
They are, while spin down,
spin down, you can't see it.
There's some spin up in there.
They're exactly on
top of each other.
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: Same energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
All the spin up
electrons when they're
paired with spin down,
they all have the same energy.
They have the exact
same position on this.
And they lead to
this total DOS here.
They just add up.
So if I did silicon
with spin polarized off,
then the answer would
be exactly the same.
So there was really no need
to do it with spin polarized,
but it's the default. And
now if I do iron, you see?
And I press simulate.
Then what you'll find is that
you should see a difference.
Let's see if we do.
Here is iron.
And now you have the
total density of states.
Oh, what is this?
I forget, is this an insulator?
AUDIENCE: No, it's
a [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: How do I know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Because
I got some DOS here, right?
At the Fermi energy.
Oh, we got to do it for iron.
And now look at this.
This is beautiful.
OK, so this is the
total, the green.
That's the total.
And look at this.
The red is the spin down.
And the blue is the spin up.
And look at those differences.
What does it mean?
Whoa!
I mean, you've got to
integrate it to know.
But there's a difference.
There's a big difference
in the spin up
and spin down
electrons and where
they sit in energy space
in the magnetic material.
There can be.
That's what makes it a magnet.
And so if you integrate
that difference up to here,
well then, you're going
to get this magnetization.
If I simulated iron with
spin polarized turned off,
it would force those
to be exactly the same,
and they would lie exactly
on top of each other,
just like they just
did in silicon.
But that would be not iron.
So you got to be aware of
what this spin thing is,
and when you need it,
when it's important.
Keeping it on is safe.
But I wanted you to
know what it means.
So OK.
Very good.
Have a good weekend.